monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur ououias depuis quelques jours
j'entends parler de ce séparatisme
scolaire au profit de l'école privée je
le redit n'opposons pas l'école publique
et l'école privée qui concourent
ensemble au service public de
l'enseignement en parlant pour le privé
de séparatisme scolaire vous stigmatisez
les choix de millions de parents je suis
très claire la République ne tolère
aucun séparatisme encore moins
s'agissant de l'école encore moins
s'agissant de ses enfants les règles qui
s appque aux établissements privés sont
celles de la République et je seraiis
intransigente sur le respect de la
laïcité comme sur le respect de la
liberté de l'enseignement nous
contrôlons sur le plan pédagogique les
enseignements de ces établissements et
nous travaillons aussi pour que toutes
les écoles soi engagé au service de
l'égalité des chances ce qui oui
implique de progresser dans la mixité
sociale et scolaire plusieurs
expérimentations ont été engagées en ce
sens à titre d'exemple toute nouvelle
ouverture de dispositifs dit
d'excellence comme les sections
internationales sont désormais soumises
à ce critère de mixité sociale pour les
dispositif de soutien comme devoir fait
nous posons cette obligation et nous
privilégions l'école publique dont nous
à qui nous dotons que nous dotons des
bons moyens un protocole également a été
signé avec le secrétariat général de
l'Enseignement Catholique avec des axes
très concrets en faveur de la mixité et
l'ensemble de ces réseaux l'ensemble de
ces établissements seront associés à
cette démarche ne faisons pas de procès
d'intention jugez-moi sur mon action de
ministre jugez-moi sur mon ambition pour
l'école publique jugez-nous sur nos
résultats au service de l'égalité des
chances et de la réussite de toutes les
écoles et de tous les enfants de ce pays
je vous
remercie